[Rires]
bon là normalement là normalement il est
condamné à mort on est d'accord c'est je
vous dis que j'attendais pas cette
blague pas mal Gilles
oui bien sûr je vous raconte avec
plaisir
moi j'en ai 5
[Rires]
alors lune dit à l'autre est-ce que tu
crois à la vie après la mort non j'y
crois pas et toi ben j'y croyais pas
mais depuis que ma belle-mère est morte
j'y crois
[Rires]
c'est pas mal allez
c'est l'histoire d'un pingouin qui
respire par les fesses
un jour il s'assoit et il meurt
[Rires]
alors cette un couple qui est le soir
dans un dans son lit est à tiens Cyril
qui est avec alors voilà donc c'est
Guillaume qui est avec sa femme
Géraldine et il se remémore un peu de
leur vie déjà c'est pas très faible
qui dit dis-moi Géraldine quand je me
suis cassé la jambe tu étais avec moi
alors Géraldine ouais j'étais avec toi
quand j'ai quand j'ai fait faillite tu
étais avec moi oui oui c'est vrai
j'étais avec toi et dis-moi et quand la
maison a brûlée
dis-moi Géraldine tu me porterais pas un
petit peu à la poisse
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est catastrophique tu vois le
talentin
la chier quoi
c'est horrible si mauvaise que ça tu
vois
chier une blague acceptable horrible toi
tu en as une ouais j'en ai moi c'est un
monde qui va voir son père et lui dit
papa je comprends pas le soir j'entends
maman elle fait des bruits bizarres avec
toi et j'ai l'impression que où vous
êtes content vous n'êtes pas content et
c'est mon fils c'est rien ce que je fais
avec maman c'est que du bonheur je lui
montre à chaque fois les clés du paradis
et le fils il regarde pas dire ouais
c'est vachement bien mais par contre tu
feras gaffe ce que le voisin hier il est
venu à 15h je crois qu'il a un double
des clés
pas mal pas mal c'est celui pour
l'instant c'est le mur
de semaine prochaine
que fait une vache quand elle a les yeux
fermés
une vache oui
déjà c'est trop long déjà c'est trop
long
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux bien donner mon temps de
parole à Jean-Marie Bigard c'est un
chien qui traverse la rue il y a une
voiture qui arrive ça fait pas fluff le
chien
[Applaudissements]
comment appelle-t-on le cul d'une
Schtroumpfette le Blu-ray
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc pour rester dans les animaux
pourquoi est-ce que les poissons nagent
dans l'eau salée parce que dans l'eau
poivrée ils étaient un humain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça sent surtout la tristesse
à son père c'est quoi la différence
entre le virtuel et le réel non non elle
est nulaine
de faire l'amour le et le mec il est un
peu penaud il dit si j'avais su que tu
étais vierge j'aurais pris mon temps et
la fille elle dit bah si tu avais pris
ton temps j'aurais retiré mon collant
connard
[Applaudissements]